j'aimerais le vélo vert à ma femme la
nouvelle impératrice lors ces questions
là vous dit maintenant vous vous taisez
mon amour bien entendu pour une fois une
immense responsabilité est un grand
honneur d'être à la tête d'un empire des
cette importance je me suis compliqué
c'est pourquoi je veux écouter ceux qui
ont un problème avec moi au liquor
oublié mais j'aimerais être utile allant
tir de russie contribué à sa grande et
vous allez porter mes qualités
vous êtes déjà utile la preuve c'est un
gourdin carte à augmenter la fertilité
mais j'hésitais ce qu'il faut que je
vous les agitent au dessus du ventre ou
que je les fours directement dedans je
pense que les agités devrait largement
suffire
ils feront une orestie plus grande c'est
moi qui dirige vous êtes à mon service
votre épouse est malheureuse il faut que
vous titiller ces nuages
il faut qu'on vous trouve une amende
[Musique]
magnifique
je préfère être seul le matin même avant
nous accueillerons semblait jour nouveau
nous avons le coeur intrépide essaieront
d'humeur règles qui tombe cette partie
de chasse pour savoir si on tue
l'impératrice ou tard c'est aussi une
étrange créature qui je crois a tendance
à se moquer
sachez que vous n'êtes pas la seule à
être malheureuse beaucoup d'hommes ne
s'y retrouvent pas une vaine infra
dirigeants si l'empereur moeurs l'envié
revient à 5 ans
et la russie doit vraiment être sauvé et
moi avec
je ne veux pas vous tuer vous n'êtes pas
quelqu'un comme toi je pourrais 28 vous
n'êtes pas mauvais vous êtes pire vous
êtes drôle on est en train de parler
d'un acte de trahison jouer un jeu
dangereux
respire airs d'opéra 10 mans à la cour
de la grande catherine dos
dans la mule vous voulez dire dans le
mille regardez la science rien que pour
vous
[Musique]